Building a business is hard.
As an entrepreneur, not only
do you need a solid product,
but you need to secure investment,
find co-founders, hire employees
and complete countless of other tasks
in pursuit of your goals.
But being an entrepreneur comes
with a ton of responsibilities,
like the freedom to be your own boss
and the chance to make a
lasting impact on the world.
Throughout this course, you're going
to get expert advice from Googlers,
from co-founders of companies,
like CrunchBase and UpWest Labs,
from investors of accelerators,
like NFX Guild
and from other Silicon Valley
business experts.
All this expertise comes together
in this course to help you to find
your business goals,
build your team around your product
and get financing to help
grow your startup.
By the end of this course, you can
have the confidence in your product
and your business.
>From there, you'll be in great shape
for the build-up product out,
go see around, fly to an accelerator,
or just bootstrap your way to success.